[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai perdu j'ai le vertige avec les
nouvelles attentes cherche les clés je
n'avais pas comme ça j'ai mal on l'a
voulu qu'on les respecte les traditions
la mariée faut assumer
moi je vais en a été cambriolée au les
salons 10 ans moi j'ai peur aux les
salomon vous allez salon à la pub
partout dans l'essonne mais non c'est
edf qui vient comme un appartement ils
apportent des fleurs c'est comme une
démarche voilà c'est tromper mais les
chouettes mariage un recompte des
guignols à 200 bornes avec les petits
fours il servait ici un an les marches
palace est trempé dans les finales ils
servent ainsi pratiquer un même de
rester planté là tu pourrais peut-être
mais les ouïes enlève son casque
tu pleures
non mais si tu perds ça fait partie du 6
mai n'ont pas les flops allait plus on
s'en fout des pleurs éponge
qu'est ce que tu fais là j'y pense
mais ces sept là tu sens pas de cscec si
c'est sec partout le bordel en rétro
couteau qu est ce que c était ça
l'argent qui l'argenterie la finul
argenterie piquer sa sortie mais salah à
la bonne heure
la pendulette la pendule est à la bonne
heure eh ben on sera réveillé par
téléphone est ce là la tortue picotte
les sel de table en écaille wall a piqué
bien de madeleine la chance j'aime pas
manège peut pas l'empêcher madeleine non
mais c'est pas possible ils sont venus
en couple ils ont déposé leurs listes
chez nous on a du pot nous dit quelque
chose on à dieu
le savez j'en étais sûr je te l'avais
dit je voulais bien des c'est un bel
effort fallait bien d une cinq points
hauts et bas quatre renforts de poids
même et on était peinard mais nous tape
avoue le comble du comble à quoi j'ai
pas voulu combler oui car si ces combles
à huy à laquelle free qu'on allait vous
avez on n'a pas un rond pour blinder et
l'ajustement blindage on le mettait sur
la liste le blindage sur la liste de
mariage
c'est poétique à ces fachos nantes ec
oui et les sets de table en détail c'est
vachement romantico ces rapports
alors d'accord la porte n'était pas
blindée mais que moi en tout cas dans le
coeur de laver avec des renforts de
paume elle risque pas de porter des
oreillettes
alors ça fait une moyenne
on est d'ailleurs complètement sûrs et
tu fous tout par terre était détruit pas
braquer cambriolé cambriolé qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un cambriolage par rapport
à nous deux on a toute la vie pour
acheter cette tagaeri c'est pas plus
important nous deux mais non du tout par
terre
bon je te demande pardon excusez moi si
j'ai réagi comme ça c'est le choc tout
ça là ça m'a fait un coup ça va pas bien
que moi non voici ça tu as fait un coup
et préfère le blindage à notre mariage
je te demande pardon à les embrasse moi
tu râles tout don au nom je t'aime on a
fait des guignols lui devant les petits
fours tu l'as dit je dis n'importe quoi
je t'aime mais pas de la manière
ça coulait ah non je t'aime tu es drôle
[Musique]
déshabillez moi
vidéo 3 fois avec les petits lots de
jupons et corset on a fait à l'époque il
y avait du suspense avec toi
oh c'est parce que la route et je te
remercie je sais bien j'aurais dû rester
plus elle n'est pas allée du v10 6
tonnes ça
non faudra mettre des rideaux parce que
avec cette enseigne
on a des têtes de vénusien tous vers un
an la gueule et même pas de voler au
prix du loyer
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais je mets mon
pantalon dans le pli vraiment aidé à
magna ouais valleyfield
j'arrive milliards oui beaucoup trop
maniaque proches
la seconde saison de seconde
mon seconde hayon ça fait vachement des
biens des fal horizontale
quelle journée j'aurais jamais cru dit
dans cette langue se marier aux hôtes et
les pieds gelés
qu'est-ce qu'on a bourré il n'a pas
entendu un bruit mais non pas maintenant
là tout à l'heure pendant le voyage en
moto parce que tu m'as fait
où j'ai rien entendu aulas s'il y avait
un bruit à moi j'en suis sûr où je
grille est une soupape où je suis en
train de serrer théâtre ici la russie
cherche pas je me fais un segment
s'il me fait à segments ben je le
descends l'embiellage les camps ils ont
rien vu à la révision et 30 min
tu te fous de ma gueule 1
tu crois vraiment que c'est le moment de
me parler de l'envié l'âge tu vois tu
râlent tout le temps mais nous on fait
l'amour
t'es pas crever mois
tu vas pas si si si elle est bien gérée
randy dont des vins très brillant
c'est l'alcool je suis trop boire mais
c'est rien enfin j'espère au titre au
cou on est complètement seul s'est tenue
complètement personnes voulu gêner
personne
rejetée
je t'aime je sais pas qui c'est allô
allô
ah oui ah oui c'est moi oui oui on est
là c'est maman
alors oui mais non n'a pas eu d'accident
non
maintenant j'ai roulé très doucement ah
oui mais non j'ai pas vu du tout non oui
tu te fais trop de soucis 1 qu'est ce
que tu dis là
mais si tu t'y fera mais si le quatuor
pas maintenant avec 10 fera date et
horaire ça paierait tous t'embrasse
moment quand brasse alors oui elle
t'embrasse aussi oui
oui au revoir maman rome s'était maman
on fait l'amour tu sais ta mère on peut
pas faire mieux comme contraceptif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
cinéma ouais ouais tu l as et entremont
conservateurs c'est la première
écossaise de chopin l'adema divine à la
tv son glk yvon rougir bons rails et
puis vers où ça assumer ma condition
féminine faire les coûts nous tu m'en
veux pas pour cette nuit on va se
rattraper aujourd'hui le téléphone est
coupé comme ça personne ne dérangera
salue tout à l'heure
[Musique]
merde qu'est ce que ce gilet pas
j'y vais voilà au pq et sur mon chéri
ben j'ai entendu j'étais au piano je
suis tapé toute la matinée mais quand à
l'épaule ne marche pas ça sonne toutes
occupées ah oui il est en dérangement
oui alors je me suis dit je vais faire
une surprise avant toi qu'as tu à porter
ça c'est vraiment une surprise
[Musique]
aïe ça c'est ça c'est une surprise oui
si tu veux qu'on le mette c'est
tellement petit ici à la 6e place
ça plaît beaucoup
tu sais que je t'aime mon toit la gitane
est quoi la prunelle de mes yeux ça a
été presque à déchirement papa maman
d'heure de voiture le cas l'équipe est
riche à l'appel ces sources
je m'en suis fait hier soir j'avais
l'impression que tu avais dérapé dans un
virage a tellement d'accidents
d'après les sondages d'après les
sondages vous chérissez linge ou 14
comme antoine et était arrivé quelque
chose mais non tu es là tu es bien là ne
dérange pas tu n'avais rien de spécial à
faire alors je vais m'habiller quand on
regarde moi tu sais que je n'arrive pas
à réaliser que tu es marié
non non non tu es toujours le petit one
pour moi donc tu one can alors ça ça n'a
pas de gêner pour canon mais qu'est ce
que tu veux imaginer ici je suis
sérieuse neuf fois sur dix avouent bon
plus doit tiens tiens regarde le mit à
la russie est installé pas maintenant
c'est trop tard puis devra faire
attention mais toi ça fait 35 ans moi ça
fait un jour envie ça mais ça passe
uniquement chez ca passe vite
c'est vrai dur les premiers temps
département un avis alors ça c'est pas
mal je ne me sens pas je suis réaliste
c'est tout jusqu'à hier je ne pouvais
pas comme imaginé que tu as lu partir
d'hier soir par exemple je croyais acte
était sorti avec des années mais ce
matin je t'ai cherché partout la chambre
vide
oui tu manière je suis un mais en me
levant ce matin j'ai mis deux temps son
petit déjeuner avant de venir j'ai eu
une arme au téléphone elle est tout seul
aussi depuis le mariage de sa fille elle
m'a dit qu'elle s'était faite à la
solitude qu'elle avait appris non mais
tu me vois avant l'agent retourner à
l'école
il faut pas que tu parles comme ça ça
fait du mal ici au contraire ça me fait
du bien
le m'a dit tu déconnes pour une piqûre
faut passer un peu avant après danse
enfant de lui
enfin presque pas
j'ai m'habiller
je te dérange mon chéri à il faut me le
dire pc je suis barras monde sur et le
lit qui n'est pas fait dès ce moment je
ferai j'ai tout ça maintenant tout but
je suis mariée maman chérie je le sais
on dirait que tu fais tout pour me le
rappeler non pendant mon toit non c'est
parce que je me le dire mais toi aussi
tu m'aimes tu m'as dit s'avère tout m'a
agacé comme avec un air de reproches à
la pomme si comme si je gênais tu
préfère avoir un appartement ranger
n'importe comment
oh je ne crois pas tu as toujours aimé
avoir tes à faire soigner alors ne me
dis pas que tu as changé en un seul jour
on aurait coûte mais maintenant c'est
pas pareil on te d'emménager
réajustement profite quand tu peux
encore man show allait aller embrasser
même antoine vous voulez
encore quelque chose qui ne va pas si je
vois encore un nuage à qui se promène
dans ta tête
c'est à moi d'être brumeuse
alors toi tu as tout pour être au beau
fixe allez dis moi ce que tu cru minla
jack était arrivée ne m'a même pas
parler de françoise j'ai invité sur
l'étude rôle kim n'a même pas laissé le
temps comment va-t-elle l essai mignonne
ça va aller très bien
j'aime rasé
il
quoi
oui c'est moi tu es là nous un de cash
flow outre son geste il faut se détendre
vous devez alors déjà dit il ya un
trophée
comment allez-vous mon petit concept là
oui je vais vous faire une surprise mais
antoine n'est pas leur 10e rase
comment auriez vous voulu que je rentre
sinon d'ailleurs j'y pense il serait
peut-être bon cros juste par simple
lorsque vous me donniez un double des
clés on ne sait jamais d'aller regarder
ce que je vous ai apporté mais vous y
attendiez pas
nous on va mettre son issue on en a
trois maires 6 passes et une telle joie
pourquoi il veut je sais que vous aimez
beaucoup le mélange de l'ancien et du
moderne ça c'est pousse bien non vous
ferai comme vous voulez entendre et bien
sûr mais franchement je pense qu'il a
trouvé là sa place rêvée pour marquer je
me suis penché mois après tout chacun
une idée bien précise de la géographie
de son petit intérieur mais franchement
ce serait tellement dommage de déplacer
à lille serait il serait qu'au moins 10
des racines et nous pas votre avis ici
je vois déjà qu'il a pris racine
mais alors quand il sera en état alors
vous verrez comme il est clair bien
parce qu'en plus il un chauffeur site
reçoit rien juste un mauvais contact
certainement j'étais tellement
impatientes de bhl apporté que je n'eus
pas comme vous les lectrices yade
les ventes wall est tellement tallinn de
ses mains et vous prépare à ça en un
clin d'oeil
ses mains
vous pouvez dire que j'en suis fier je
les connais tellement je les connais
aussi un nom au petit non pas comme moi
depuis toujours je les observe et dès la
première heure j'ai su qu'elle serait
d'exception le jour où vous y lirez
comme moi à livre ouvert alors ce jour
là vous comprendrez vraiment antoine
je vous demande de le rendre heureux
tine 13 0
si vous saviez la chance que vous avez
l'immense chance ils ont mangé un petit
bouton qui va se déclare athée là je
suis pas entendu rentrer et a fait vite
maman nous avons des visites gifle
qu'est ce que tu as acheté pour manger
chéri avocat choukoud de fruits de la
choucroute maintenant comme antoine ne
vous a pas tu mets la choucroute le mot
vient sceller ce moment non il ne m'a
pas encore donné sa liste de contre
indications tu vois mais tu n'es pas un
homme dangereux n'importe quoi déjà
enfant il vomissait tout serpent
pourtant dieu sait si je veillais à la
composition de ces mules mon ami témoin
pour le médecin de famille spécialiste
de rien à faire jusqu'au jour j'ai enfin
compris la pose et monsieur se gaver
dans la gamelle du chien est un lieu qui
croyant que des canaris telia moment
tombé de françoise avec des histoires
vois pas du tout mais comment veux-tu
qu'elle devine ce petit homme stupide et
rien parce que tu l'a jamais dit bien
sûr qu'il faisait une katzen chronique
ça n'a pas d'importance comment pas
d'importance mais ces noms de m une
choucroute sur une gastrite y en as tu
verras tu verras mais je vais très bien
maman je vais très bien et que tu me dit
ou tu dis mais ménages ta santé vous y
verrez montpetit
bon
eh bien j'ai aussi un ne mange un peu
malheureusement rester déjeuner avec
vous tu pourras me de venir à maryse de
toute façon je crois que vous avez un
programme très chargé
j'allais oublier
en faisant le lit j'ai vu que vous
n'aviez qu'une couverture c'est trop
pour les nuits rafraîchissant ce moment
nous en apporte à une
je vais être en retard ou maman pwan
labonté surveiller le bien non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que tu as
qu'est ce que tu fais là
dans quel état tu mets la chambre arrête
arrête qu'est ce que j'ai fait réponse -
françoise je veux pas me parler tu n'as
aucun souci à se faire pour le rangement
j'ai trouvé une femme de ménage culture
accord ta mère est absolument parfaite
30 soigner même pas la peine de lui
donner 14 39 en prime elle se fera un
plaisir de faire des heures
supplémentaires toujours à l'oeil alors
vraiment tellement de pop
françois c idiote
non réaliste tu laisserais passer une
aussi belle occasion d'accord une
occasion qui a déjà pas mal de
kilomètres au compteur mais avoue quand
même quelle affaire à part les autres
mandats maire excuse moi je t'aimerai
toujours être très correcte avec les
domestiques ou tu te rends compte de ce
que tu dis mais sûr je suis un directeur
sûreté par an je vois pas pourquoi il ne
pas camper ici au moins on va pas passer
la journée là dessus elle vient laver
jeune et j'ai enfin tu fais ce que tu
veux à givet tu vis trop dangereusement
est à gastrite tu recommences non là je
suis très sérieuse
on n'est jamais assez prudent avec la
choucroute
on marche qui a déjà voilà qui est
heureusement la moitié a alors là j'en
ai marre là j'en ai marre tu prennes
scène pour rien strictement pour rien
parce que tu appelles ça pour rien toi
ta mère série en tête
elle vient ici à saastal fff et où on
pourrait aussi le faire à l'abonnement
pour dire la chandelle bon on exagère
tout six agir quoi elle m'a demandé lui
donner à double des clés tu trouves ça
normal
mais à ce trailer dans une semaine elle
fait souche ici ce sera fantastique
comme n'atteindra que la taille demain
mais je vous en prie la bravo belle
avance mais on pourrait parler tes
parents aussi un vase ils ont vu et ton
père t'a pas quoi ah bah quoi pourquoi
ton père qui faisait la gueule parce que
les petites nations
papa il a plus aucun souci à se faire on
est me plaît aussi
on vient déjà de recevoir l'éclairage
c'est une pièce unique on en trouve
notre pas grande soupe de l'allée pierre
rien hein pas rose en c'est pas tes
parents qui vous aurait donné un sou
parce que tu vas y pousse et brûlent
fric ça tokamak 130 fois aussi ce sera
plus régulier comme convenu tu fais pas
un rond
très bas et je dis pas là la valise ou
dumas cherchait un mec
[Applaudissements]
elle
[Musique]
oh
on
non
[Musique]
je te dérange pas
non si si je te dérange du travail et
j'ai entendu le piano j'ai reconnu
c'était du debussy nord du sati première
gymnopédies payet excuse moi je déraille
complètement c'est pas grave vieux ils
sont contemporains tous les deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va ok c'est là haut
en fait ça va moyen c'est la merde
qu'est ce que tu as non non rien je
passe juste cinq minutes je ne fermais
la boucherie je veux pas de bassiner
avec mes fantasmes
t'es vachement épanouie quitté cat alors
qu'ils comprennent qu'ils peuvent faire
comprendre ça a été dur ce matin ça même
été assez violent avec charlotte et avec
charlotte pour des bricoles
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il ya eu je te
dis et bricole laisse tomber hockey en
plus c'était son anniversaire j'étais
sûr que ça lui plairait à critique de la
raison pure de kant et manas avait parlé
la semaine dernière va me chercher à la
boucherie
or ce matin je veux faire le bouc a pas
de la merde relier pur pas de casquette
année c'est foutu aschieri vient alors
le grand jeu en ce moment elle est en
pleine déprime tu comprends elle se
remet en question et me sortit a été
complètement ratée qui a été fini
qu'elle est plus goût à rien tv en noir
et blanc
enfin plein de trucs de cette eau là
alors ma tuque orange moi j'essaie de la
remontée j'ai dit que tel grand berger
pour rien qu'elle était comme de se
taper noir et blanc qu'avec à se payer
la couleur qu'on avait les moyens et non
l affaire elf ya les echirey une averse
une averse finalement ça s'est gâté
quand je me dis qu avant de s'emballer
on n'avait pas le droit d'avoir des
joueurs de ménopause et a répondu quoi
mais que j'étais un minable une brute
que je pouvais retourner à ma vie
d'homme ça m'a fait un coup tu vois je
me suis adressé au tabouret la cuisine
histoire d'essayer décompresser et tu
parles impossible j'ai balancé dessus tu
lui as le tabouret j'aurais pas dû
elle l'a pris comme en bas sur l'arcade
sourcilière au nord c'était trois fois
rien trois points de suture c'est tout
j'ai emmené à cochin j'ai un pote là-bas
callas pour au coude c'est lui qui
s'occupe de nous à la fédération de boxe
il agit pour tricoter avis tiens regarde
voit rien enfin presque
c'est pourtant c'est encore tout frais
deux mois appelle un combat ma main aux
centrales contre bensaïd le petit bras
patrol et il m'arrive la toile je vais
attaquer scientifique tu vois que tu vas
tendinite au coude parce que je peux pas
forcer du cochon le public pour moi et
il est vide et lille tenus à distance
qui valide les biens par un poteau de
ring guidon à ce moment c'était pas beau
à sa fille c'est le sens antoine
soubigou tu as raté comme si je te
dégoûte je le vois dans ton oeil
qu'est ce que tu sens il ya une odeur et
ça sent le bonheur je fais toi
on n'a pas erré effectué comment tu mets
kurt et premier partout l'amour la
musique
pourquoi j'ai jamais le moyenne mois un
téton bois pour coller ce que tu connais
avec françoise moi je donnerai tout la
boutique la boxe fait trotter pas
seulement là tous des problèmes
ouais 2k sports a inventé pour me
remonter le moral un tas toujours la
météo au beau fixe
moi c'est tellement je dis ça fait péter
baromètre comment il faisait pour être
heureux toi je sais pas j'improvise
ouais t'as du pot de paille sans filet
oh non non non en fait on se trouve je
vais te dire un truc c'est vachement
sérieux quand je fais l'amour maintenant
j'arrive pas à me concentrer
ça fait un mois qu'il jouit plus vous en
avez parlé oued deux jours avant le bon
bout de ce matin remarque a été
vachement sympa on était tous et m'a pas
mis en cause non elle m'a dit qu'a été
victimes d agressions de cette société
d'animation qu'a réussi à lui polluer
son orgasme
il m'a dit aussi que à force de nous
coller dieu 412 dans les yaourts il
avait fallu finir par de castries tu
sais qu'elle est vachement regarder un
psychanalyste les scripts athée tu
penses à quoi toi quand tu fais l'amour
à tout sauf au yaourt moi aussi
justement c'est ce que je dis mais
qu'est ce que tu as répondu eh ben que
je baiser comme un mec de droite
ouais bon alors là il n'y a pas que la
psychanalyse un nom elle est vachement
bien j'ai aussi un hit roule super
engagé et le mythe comme une dingue
à la télé il doit aussi de la virée
plusieurs femmes ils peuvent pas aller à
la tête d'un groupuscule révolutionnaire
ouais et est vachement généreuse aussi
un faut voir comment elle se bat contre
les facisme mois avant politiquement tu
vois je pensais pas plus loin que le
pâté de nom mais depuis combien son
petit peu parce qu'elle est de savoir si
elle m'a ouvert les yeux
tiens je vais te dire un truc tu vas pas
me croire
et souvent le matin de bonne heure vers
les 5 6 heures quand je désosse un boeuf
et ben je pense au chili
et il m'a même pas de potes venus à ton
mariage y ait au nom du roi moi j'ai
insisté pour grenelle mais c'était le
car faisait complètement catégorique
pourquoi pas s'ils font contre le
mariage elle dit que c'est une
célébration bourgeoise qui tend à
chloroformé l'affectivité par la
libération du mois pour profit d'une ou
textos bah dis donc ça en dit des trucs
au scrutin et toi t'en penses quoi
ben moi je trouve que ça discute mais je
respecte ses idées ap les idées c'est
comme les goûts il y en a qui préfèrent
la bavette de l'araignée pourquoi je te
le demande pourquoi es tu trouves pour
sa sortie bientôt et je trouve que vous
faites un couple marc webb
tu trouves que les comics si tu veux way
est vachement d'humour
actuellement elle est en train d'écrire
un scénario ces histoires de la
chauffeur outil qui fait le bilan de sa
vie entre régis et cavaillon toute
l'action se passe uniquement sur la
banquette à l'arrière du semi remorque à
part un moment fantastique en plein air
quand il crève et ça s'appelle comment
la banquette
moi j'y crois à fond dans son très calme
et le le drame du convoi le drame
s'était alors il faut le finir et
croient pas en elle et ceux des primes
pourra rien quoi bon faire tout petit je
te remercie vous avez fait vachement
diverses que tuvalu
je sais que tu me confronte l artiste a
vachement de facile
dites moi que ça va pouvoir partir en
train your way mais oui mais oui mais
faut pas que tu crois du noir comme si
internet extrait je sens que je vais
déjà mieux se dit don mais t'as qu'à
venir on allait verser dans quelques
jours photo cl vient des quêtes ferrari
mais tu vas sa télé en forme il est
super bien nommé autres saluent un salut
vieux os
la toussaint regarde-moi l'antispam
salut
j'ai oublié de te dire vachement punk'd
aux réverbères une botte on se téléphone
[Applaudissements]
excessive h marthaler vachement fort moi
aussi je suis mal si amoureux je pense à
l'hosto au téléphone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue oui chérie faut pas qu'on se
fasse la gueule c'est fini tu vois c'est
moi qui fait le premier pas c'est
toujours moi qu'est ce que tu faisais
bien que j'y vais pas là un monsieur
reçoit les cantons mon absence
j'avais téléphoné chez là où je suis sûr
qu'il était chez lui 3 je n'étais pas
shira où tu étais ou alors ça regarde
moi si ça me regarde les jaloux 1
mais qu'est ce que tu voulais que je
fasse moi j'étais au bistrot la fin j'en
ai ras le bol il ya des mecs qui
commençait à me draguer je recommence à
je te crois pas qu'elle ait envie de
quitter pas mal un grand flou et je fais
tout frisé visionnaire je ne crois pas
tu veux que tu es encore jaloux mine où
il faut plus qu'on se fasse demain non
tu me promets je te promets il faut qu
on se préserve ses 28 à tous les deux
n'ont rien que nous deux tu meures
promener je te reprend même journée
jacques jure 13 par terre
maintenant la moquette toi tu call crash
voilà un menteur t'as pas trash et à
postillonner c'est moi j'en a gâché un
peu de la première journée
on va se rattraper on va sélectionner ok
y'a white knight story au kinopanorama
on a juste la taille et on y va tout de
suite on s'est dit c'est parti oui hélas
après on s'est tous dit dont on l'espère
de la choucroute et à castres est allé
magne on va louper la séance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu tard
et tu dors
moi je n'arrive pas avec cette saloperie
danse elle
on
qu'est ce qu'il ya rc rien tiers sais
rien je fais un rideau de la nuit je
reviens pour fixer c'est très bruyant
quand tu fais des rideaux bien sûr
excuses moi si j'étais réveillé j'étais
en train de rêver
c'est ce à quoi bon on est qui dans une
grande grande prairie et escompter des
rideaux on faisait l'amour
c'était fantastique merde étaient tous
deux vers quel dédaigné sur nos cheveux
c'est normal avec cette saloperie dans
ces noms là même les rêves colorés en
vert l'instant détaille le rapport
[Musique]
il faudra au moins trois épaisseurs donc
la lumière pour sport si encore ça
clignote et pas marque en mettant entre
la doublure il tissu une bonne épaisseur
de molleton bien prises en sandwich
je suis sûr que je l'aurais ve c'est ça
la vie photo ahmad nazif
ce qui est pratique pour moi c'est que
pour voir leur c'est comme en plein jour
13h50 dumont conservatoire demain allez
on pioche au oui
bon
on
puis d'or ouais mais tu étouffes non
c'est pas comme ça ça va
mignon fait l'amour
maintenant bah oui maman qui vous jamais
jeu si je veux maintenant j'ai mal au
coeur
qu'est ce que t'en fous digère pas si
j'ai passé la pizza et pizza ne passe
pas il était dégueulasse ton resto à ta
prime quoi toi moi j'ai pris une vision
à oui c'est vrai oui je t'ai rien dit
mais tu avais eu l était pas mais tu
n'as vésuve panet
j'ai pas trop beau aussi pour moi
j'aurais jamais dû prendre une caprice
de la mer oh c'est dangereux les fruits
de mer 1
c'est sûrement une moule pas fraîche et
c'était pas des moules c'était décote
bien même une coque ça suffit l'hépatite
montre tu as sûrement une hépatite pitt
ouvert en de confort
c'est vachement fréquents une hépatite
et ça serait complètement dramatique une
hépatite avec mon concours
mais quand on concourt dans sept mois
aux joueurs merde dans le temps de la
voir tout ça pour moi
mais où tu vas
l'agglo minérales dans le frigo tu as
raison je crois qu'il faut toujours
prendre de l'eau minérale avant de faire
l'amour rien
ça va mieux
marc tu as raison c'est peut-être pas
forcément une hépatite parce qu'il ya le
cinéma ont été complètement devant en
plus sur le côté à la machette natale et
roudet
ça va mieux moi tu dors oui je dors
non mais tu dors tu dors le tintamarre
et être contagieux
deux communes hépatites tu crois qu'on
plaisante avec une hépatite ou arrête
déjà que je m'inquiétais avec tyga
street alors madame hépatites l'avenir
les bouchons on va faire l'amour tu sais
comment je le vois l'avenir est des
vignes des milliers de bouteilles d'eau
minérale que j'arrivais pas à décapsuler
maintenant tu vois c'est quand tu
continues l'aller viens j'ai épousé une
bouteille d'eau minérale bord dont
paraître tu veux vraiment faire l'amour
avec ton des capsules est d'accord au
une condition si tu as besoin de voir
cette image mais quand il a connu titi
n'a battu leur coutances enfants
demeurent monsoise on va réviser la
baraka coup d'envoi ya toujours un truc
à l'être humain on s'en fout de la
baraque
tu te souviens oui bah rien oui j'étais
venu chez tes parents mais cram le
[ __ ] il draguait y avait une ville si
c'est vite je n'avais jamais vu ça il
faisait une percée en impressionner
lâche tu te souviens il ya quoi
il revenait de son premier match de boxe
amateur deux incisives sucre est
aujourd'hui une assise hit-parade papa
d'un petit noir tourab les travées de
talent et vous lui direz vous mais dans
ma chambre je vais vous montrer mon gars
veaux cochons
le coup classique non je n'ai pas dit ça
enfin je n'ai pas dit ça comme ça mais
si non je t'ai dit mademoiselle
auriez vous la gentillesse de rentrer
dans la chambre je vais vous montrer mon
gaveau nuance
[Musique]
e
on était tous les deux que ferait
exactement
j'étais folle de tournai jaser la patte
folle et en
jouer nos champs je vis c'est le voisin
on va faire l'amour
tudor
[Musique]
c'est quoi et j'ai pu tourner marianne
aquarium caméra c'est fantastique on
peut pas imaginer une fois ce taux est
plus résistante
normalement c'est sa vie dans le box
dans le bassin de lamelles on est et
dans le 15e arrondissement a aucun
problème ça supporte le voyage puis vous
allez pouvoir vous lancer dans l'élevage
intensif
je te jure s'être produit plus vite que
des rations touché des viennent au
quotient familial pour ces bestioles en
aurait plus besoin de bosser et connais
pas tu vas tout renverser olharan la fin
j'ai l'habitude depuis je me suis trouvé
un job à la branche et exotique une
boutique prête pas si je suis devenu un
professionnel de l'as des joueurs m'a
finalement lâché la solution j'ai un
boulot pas comment puis je peux me payer
mes cours d'art dramatique en vendant du
poisson jetez pas les suit aussi des
cours de claquettes et ça c'est génial
pour la souplesse et ayari chabadabada
voilà enfin pas à la banane acp konare
alamo que toi cool cool et froid de
l'ariège qui te rend nerveux et ça jette
un kyste en pense
superbe problème c'est pour le nourrir
ravalec tu leur donnes ça
voilà une fois par jour et surtout très
peu à chaque fois sans ça ils vont
devenir comme moi et eux je t'aimais
appelé qu'aux mu ce à quoi un pl est
costaud mais on l'appelle aussi poisson
laveur tu vas voir avec sa gueule en
forme de ventouses
il va te servir de femmes de ménage en
boule dans tout les algues vertes qui se
dépose sur les huîtres mais le problème
c'est pour les vacances un toit puis il
faut entamèrent se fera un plaisir de
les biberonné au poste originales comme
cadeau de mariage si survêtement
convaincu
moi je trouve que c'est mieux qu'un
aspirateur
oui j'avais aussi penser à des oiseaux
tu aurais préféré pendant les choisit on
se chie partout ouais m'enfin s'achète
quand même seul l'hommage que françois
chouet web télé ou est à la fac n'a pas
tardé à entrer je vais prêter la moto et
et et 7 fait qu'il ait fait est marié il
ya pas comme si j'avais la peste j'ai
pas changé en quarante huit heures au
début mais après quand jouer les copains
mais moi je suis un peu à plat pour la
vie déjà direct pour apprendre la
conduite sur neuf mois à propos ça va
comment avec nathalie abord parce que ta
maison tu m'as appris que vous étiez
parti pour une longue traversée les
bermudes de way et bbq voilà final on
aura qu'on dépense et la baie de
quiberon
et pourtant l'actrice était une fille
gains solides responsable on est à dire
c'était c'était leur art et un une
rareté à brno rareté puis alors d'un
d'un maternelle tout m j'ai vu une femme
aussi m'interner la 4l en voulait 4,4
alors la femme doit pas bien quand je te
dis la femme pour la famille comme ça
toute la femme comme ça doit fuir sa
faveur à la fin je voulais jetons j'ai
rompu
maintenant j'ai josiane josiane avait
adressé moi tu connais pour jonnier et
donc tu vas vite la soul lui aurais je
vienne c'est une tondeuse tondeuse ouais
c'est elle qui s'occupe du toilettage
des chiens à la broche et exotiques
alors d'accord josiel question elle a
présenté la chaudière à gaz à la
question de tempérament
c'est une rareté
non ça on peut pas dire non mais faut
quand même que je vous la présente
qu'est ce que vous faites à la fin de la
semaine
ah non c'est pas possible on va au bord
de la mer françoise ne rêve que de saab
à l'achat chez le mariage c'est comme ça
le mariage à la hausse remplie aux
idoles
on érige les copains du menez riches
c'est pas bien c'est bon enfin j'étais
promis de m'occuper de thèmes regorgent
us à nantes un erp avec sa guerre d'alan
ont jeté promis je t'ai promis puis les
étages c'est ma spécialité c'est
essentiel électro je vais chercher les
codes que je reviens bidon ça c'est pas
bien de le négliger comme ça tu sais
c'est pas bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est moi salut c'est toi un casque
c'est un potager non je trouve ça
marrant que je vais te faire une soupe
formidable qui fait vachement froid
dehors ça était ce matin conservatoire
ouais j'ai vu ma wii d'après lui il m'a
parlé d'une boîte qui cherchait un
pianiste il donnerait 120 balle pour
jouer entre 11 heures et 3 heures du
matin quoi tu vas peut être à la maison
quoi le bâton s'est pas fait faut passer
les auditions ici ou c ou à pigalle
parce qu'en plus c'est à pigalle
il cherche pas une strip teaseuse non 1
et quoi qu'est-ce que c'est un cadeau de
raoul jean yanne j'étais pressé d'en
avoir enfin voilà c'est fait c'est quoi
comme grâce à un des cubis salut fis non
qpi salut ça me fait penser tout ça non
on remet ça ce sont des poissons d'eau
douce au feu vert ça tu penses d'accord
je pense pour ne pas oublier d'oublier
mais en fleurs on va passer trois jours
merveilleux là bas ça sera notre voyage
de noces au hockey cc pour défaut chez
ça vaut largement banni
nous oui faut que je te dise quelque
chose
quoi je te le dis parce qu'on s'est juré
de jamais rien se cache et les deux faux
riches tout à l'heure après la fac
bon alors j'ai fait des petites courses
pour ce soir et le reprenons la route ou
encore pendant la moto y avait plus
d'essence si vite compris moi j'avais
les mains très embarrassé alors elle est
tombée de la béquille
merde ça y est tu vois tu cries mais
c'est trois fois rien mon pauvre
bonhomme ya juste trois petites bosses
sur le toit du réservoir mais alors tout
donné ils terminèrent merde merde tu
appelles ça trois fois rien j'aurais
jamais dû tout après tlt petit brad est
même pas capable de la soulever
c'est terminé ça je ne te dirai plus
rien voilà à quoi ça sert que tu prends
pour un contrôle on serait pas aperçu de
toutes façons tu as beau temps ça compte
plus que moi si tu pouvais coucher avec
mais tu l'a montré le mieux avec ta mère
son porte bagages alors est acquis
bonsoir antoine nous pousse à mon pied
j'ai quelque chose pour vous quelque
chose qui va vous faire plaisir
c'est la surprise yaro toi tu as obtenir
plus bas c'est quelque chose qui va vous
faire plaisir
quelques halls à +51 de raul mais bien
un cadeau empoisonné à vous ne verrez
jamais la fin pour l'entretien on
croirait pas mais c'est fou ce que c'est
sale c'est bête la rouille annoncé que
je vous importez les doubles brigands de
tâches en vaut deux garçons c'est pas de
bol idée mon françoise boulet en achetez
achetez achetez qu'elle ne trouve pas
mal bâti s'intègrent parfaitement
c'est vraiment une chance ça ne va pas
du tout une couleur ben justement c'est
toute l'astuce faut créer une harmonie
parfaite opposition
bon là c'est pour opposer sérieusement à
faire aménager un petit intérieur c'est
ma passion j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
décoratrice d'appartement
des projets d'études attend un muscat
bout salut c'est vrai où étaient rentrés
trois mois toujours à croquer c'est
pourquoi celui ci n'ont accès tadros à
ma musique au pardon j'oubliais que tu
es marié hart lane racing jet et futurs
de meetic fr n'est parfaite petite femme
d'intérieur l'attention des siens il ya
douze ans le go soit pas content
m salle à l' attention tu vas tomber
assez carrière j'ai toujours eu le
vertige
il paraît que l' équilibre se tient dans
les oreilles pourtant j'entends très
bien que ça va s'arranger ça commence en
elle tout le temps qu'elle passe sa vie
ici c'est pas de la colle c'est de
l'abus
qu'est ce qu'elle fout bien pour le
moment historique à vous s'ils voulaient
casser la gueule à tous
attention ces chérubins dieu voulait
genre à la droite si tu savais comme je
travaillais pour vous les faire aussi
vite
non mais rends-toi conte il a fallu tout
à bâtir pour les adapter à vos fenêtres
c'est françoise qui doit être heureux ah
oui c'est pas pour dire mais là je fais
en lettres une belle épine du pied
tous les fils étaient pourris à
l'intérieur dans quel état il était
nommé rhodia les laisse tomber ça va
s'arranger
no comment antoine ne dit rien généré
faut le comprendre aussi tu sais il a
perdu son père y à peine un an alors il
se rattrape sur dix était normale mais
elle s'est toujours rattraper sur lui
même avant on a fait le centre de
l'univers
comment bill cosmique positif même pas
ses yeux elle est tombée vous allez vous
boirez trois jours à la fin de la
semaine ça allait s'arranger se dit
shanahan jamais tu te rends compte comme
le temps passe vite
j'ai acheté deux jardinières pour le
cimetière j'y mettrai des chrysanthèmes
bon moment toile heureusement que tu
seras là promet d'y aller porter parce
que c'est si lourd avec la terre tu
compte y aller quand tu as samedi pour
dire non non c'est non c'est pas
possible elle françoise on on veut
partir non non non non non non mais tu
n'y penses pas mais c'est son premier
anniversaire
puis ç'a tellement heureuse de voir
françoise bailly les bêtas
les frères marc et puis je connais un
hôtel fut fait en amont fleurs donc
génial
la bouche joue sur le port très heureux
comme des coqs en pâte puis quand je
vous passerais bien deux pattes comme ça
vous gérez moins qu'avec la moto ouais
je sais je sais ça marche d'un ken
l'électricité one a pas de secret dans
deux minutes j'allume la bête et passe
c'est vraiment scandaleux savait au
moins six mois que le marbrier m'a
promis d' arranger la tout six mois et
toujours rien non mais le drame c'est
que la dalle fille qu'elle entend pauvre
père qui prend l'eau mais parfois les
fils oh attention plus de ce dangereux
là dessus bon attention salut maman
si la tendance allant mon amour de films
présents charmant miev la foudre est
tout du monde où je te ferai minette eu
le plaisir bien
[Musique]
coc
[Applaudissements]
patrice verry v rai et du madrier john
murphy bowe trimble
[Musique]
le style est l'actionnaire sur
l'attention les gauchistes va couler sa
fin les ont partout un conseil pour pas
louper tu sers effet c'est tout l'art
les abdos les bêtises d'un moment on a
tiré trop ont fait rétro avec santé
légitime et aux 3000 arnaud il va passer
vite hein j'ai mon concours
et oui mais moi si différents
branchements fut presque un prêche
gratuitement
je sais mais toujours ajournées est
première et est péché mortel
[Musique]
antoine labouchère le lieu
et on le nesc question est un problème
non deux au moins j mais ses gaffes et
les effets le docteur freud à près de 80
hors jeu suivant finalement ça fait un
bail quoi c'est pour lui un sérieux
nerveux son boss son buzz ses propres au
plus tôt de se voir ses cours
moi je tournais un job à la branche et
exotiques
il est chouette lapone c'était 7,10 ses
prolifiques ses vaches veaux produits
laitiers
et
début le tumulte ans
[Musique]
hélas flatteur non mais qu'elles
flottent au vent aux touches le fond on
touche le fond
il vole printemps mois il faut attendre
tu bosses toujours été oui un quart des
besoins et la face à ceux qui veulent ça
c'est bien ça lui apporter toujours ce
crime dans ces métiers là à ce qu'il dit
faut être précis et tout mais je
pourrais pas eu vent des ligues alors
corps d'élite complètement mais un truc
qui serait sa presse et causeront région
sur un plateau de télé tous les deux ans
mettra une ambiance du tonnerre
enfin moi surtout parce que toi on la
veut jetons évidente et la shoah ce
quinté
qu'est ce que c'est cette année fillon
nous a accueillis c'est un accident de
voiture
imaginons thème du pot 1 la justice et
moi j'ai un coffret avec un jour en
voulant éviter un club si c'est payant
tilleul argenté poids de ceinture le nul
entre amis aïe ça se passait à redon
ille et vilaine
mon copain aussi les miennes enfin sur
le plan des chirurgies esthétiques ardo
sont indécis et or d'après l'onem et ont
explosé de partout à 10 ans j'allais
leur union
le déjà l'édredon un biais de la ville
de redon est chargé de redonner à été
initial de la ville gravée super bon
j'aimerais emmener le champagne bar ilan
le docteur freud il est à deux doigts de
l'année nous mais c'est qu'on est là
tout pour plaire à quoi paul savoir sans
pas bloqué allez-vous y avoir plus
petits talons compensés
oui il aime bien les talons compensés
d'ailleurs elle adore tout ce qu'ils
avaient trop comédien avant guerre moi
je tiens maintenant parce qu'à la grande
époque des stars on n'aurait pas pu se
rencontrer dai et méformes boutique
d'aquarium
[Musique]
oui moi enfin même métier on est dans le
commerce mais la boucherie voilà ça va
être plus dur
mais comment on fait le matin vous
est-il au jeu mais le réveil malin
je pourrais pas longtemps gelé des
boules quiès forcément mon studio donne
son périphérique le ouest 1 ces peluches
a rejeté lors d'un bruyant
bon cette fois sa peau mais c est pas
les marécages montargis amuse toi bien
fait gaffe le terrain est miné
[Musique]
soir charlotte
mg il m'a dit que vous écriviez à
scénario formidable il exagère
moi aussi je la trouve très très bonne
votre histoire du routier là
[Musique]
à pied en plus sur le plan financier ces
maps a réclamé un gros gros budget je
vois bien et 1000 dans le rôle pas vous
il n'a pas son permis
sofia mois ferme et fort que l'on va
quoi pas rater quand même un sourire
chavez caladois c'est un comédien et
musicien serbe à tort que c'est ça aussi
ce que tu aimes sion ces polymères n'y a
pas besoin
embratur ça va être à moi ta main tu
danses volontiers sa beauté
c'est dur aussi la tonte 1 au début j'ai
cru ne m'habituerai jamais quitté plein
de boutons alors heureusement mon
dermatologue m'a soigné je faisais des
allergies plus des convois de griffon
pourquoi froid et dur est fausse et
surtout avec des phoques
j'ai été mordu deux fois aussi hargneux
et roth
il est rentré dans une partie très
secrète ça aussi un citoyenne entre
commerçants haut laissant pas ton amusé
mais le rôle a l'air vachement intérieur
un tu vas de cartes et la déformation
professionnelle est vachement car sans
van et pagnol 1 3 million au tessin
l'oxygène
[Musique]
m
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à toi tu riais 23h45 elle attendit
calquer ma bonne odeur celle où elle est
arrivée ici que demain ne redescend
soient prudents après tranquille mais
grosse poule c les mots pour dit la môme
qui va là où il faudrait quand même pas
loin
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est la tranche sociale et la paix rhdp
bédié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
oui j'ai bien vite on a des naissances
au nom si regarde moi c'est pareil il y
en a combien à 2 3 4 5 6 ya 1,6 à
l'incroyable cool qui sont à mes frais
qui déjà comme des gardons non comme des
groupies tu as raison
voilà il y en a qui fait des nichons
très costaud nuit non mais tu crois
qu'il fera voix semblant de s'intéresser
tu parles sans fond et qu'on peut le
faire les carreaux j'ai vachement est
quant à lui stable est costaud mais non
consciencieux boulot boulot
nuance allez si on se couchait un regard
dont tu as bu leur regard voilà la soul
roches il y en a qui ne lui presque pas
il a raison allez on fait comme les
biens au noir 4 c'est la joie regarde
elle est mal formés complètement trophy
on va pas après sos vétérinaire
allez viens vite te coucher j'ai mon
concours demain
il n'a pas passé la nuit l'état normal
lorsque tu consommes comme place ou
alors là vraiment te manque pas d'air
je suis tout d'abord vous verriez à ma
chute dans le vide
tenable en ce moment c'est pas de ma
faute si on est trois
et que tu fais
tu dire les bras
mais vraiment aidé à magnac c'est pas
possible coûtant geffroy samarie vos
épaules
tu as peur d'attraper une angine wenzhou
c'est un mois de juin très frais
deux mamans et fait deux choses c'est
normal ton petit chauffage central
portatif
allez construire vélo
au fond
en ce moment je n'arrête pas d'y penser
bah quoi synavi abb à normand le sort
commence ça m'a repris en voyant la
nageoire du cubi tu sais la semaine
dernière je t'ai rien dit mais j'en ai
encore extérieur - était tout à fait
normal maintenant pourquoi toute
angoisse
pascal terry remet de quoi
intérieurement intérieurement quand on
lui a fait une prise de son il avait le
centre bell même patate c'est l'enseigné
je sais bien j'y peux rien contient peu
de rideau c'est un beau terrain
convertir pour en mettre d'autres elle
n'allait pas le garder c'est est d'une
laideur et puis je peux pas acheter les
rideaux tant qu'on n'a pas le papier
c'est pas possible j'ai parfois même
plus avec toi c'est comme pour le perso
depuis le temps qu'ils devraient être là
le versant est une angoisse encore pour
rien mg il m'a dit qui s'en charge et on
n'a pas balancé par un pour rien tu
parles qu'il a d'autres chats à fouetter
be et pense qu'à sa sélection pour le
championnat de france du président à la
tête et un berceau toi si on dort met
donc de se torturer avec des détails
c'est
je tends nuit avec mes lecteurs mais
dans quel état je vais cependant
concours demain au ces des problèmes de
nahla enfin de manas pas très
appétissant traque plus et ça redémarre
non je t'assure jeunes tourtereaux
chauriens c'est tout à fait normal
enfin quand même ça fait combien de
temps qu'on n'a pas fait l'amour mais ça
serait de l'alpinisme a maintenant je ne
te reproche absolument rien c'est tout à
fait normal
finalement pour les quatre derniers mois
on devrait nous enfermer dans des
centres spécialisés dans des espèces de
serre conventionné ou ont géré murray
loin de vous comme ça en vous pour
préparer
tu dis vraiment des conneries tu m'as tu
le crois je crois plus je dors
oh mais tu m'embrasses
côté alpinisme a baissé jusqu'à béziers
c'est quand même pas de la haute
montagne
allez bonne nuit
oh merde j'étais presque huit mois si
j'étais pas ce qu'est ce que c'est
mais quel est le con qui vient à 3
heures du matin qui s'appelle mais je
sais pas moi relève pas du ciel à givet
autres otages est très peu vous dérange
qu'est ce que tu fous ici je vous
dérange vous dormiez nombreuses et t'as
pas vu le soleil à 3h du mat aveuglant
en france pas mon but j'ai vachement
hésité à alimenter un cas je vous ai
apporté le berceau j'espère qu'il paiera
françoise tu vois c'est finalement je
les prix avec des bords assez oh [ __ ]
modèles complètement nouveaux tu
comprends antichute
la vendeuse me l'a conseillé d'abord il
ya il ya un frein c'est utile en cas de
forte et puis surtout les verrous sont
montés sur le moabi ce qu'il faut que je
t'explique sur peut le transformer
complètement landau c'est utile aussi tu
comprends intérieur/extérieur fou
réversible il ya études dans la bagnole
faut pas plus de cinq minutes pour
levante du mécano tu comprends la
couleur tu la trouves comment suivre une
à trois heures du matin pour nous
apporter le perso il plaît pas
antoine que c'est une ville qui l'a
d'ailleurs il passait nous apportait le
perso quoi
qu'est ce qui est arrivé c'est le
batteur électrique à la maison tout
emile bator et it dans la loi c'est
charlotte qui me l'envoyer je vous
emmerde avec mes problèmes
pas du tout viata soir oulala ça s'est
passé quand ce soir juste avant le dîner
avec cuisine les posies des oeufs à la
neige
ça a été très violente au creux double
et pourquoi j'ai fait une connerie rien
où il avait quoi vraiment pas en quoi
rien j'ai trompé au top elle s'attrape
henry donc mais juste une fois c'était
uniquement physique elle a su comment va
jouer dix ans du [ __ ] parce que toi tu
aurais rien dire mais c'était
complètement physique
on s'était dit qu aux dires et tous
étaient à une convention entre nos pas
de monopole sexuelle c'était son
principe
alors j'étais en confiance mais mais le
drame tu comprends le drame c'est que ça
a été dramatique elle l'a très mal pris
est devenu comme feue la cuisine il ya
plus de cuisine alors je suis je suis
parti je vous emmerde avec mes problèmes
c'était complètement physique mais il
faut faire mais je pense est couché sur
votre banc là quoi et comment si je
rentre ce soir ça va être la catastrophe
est capable de tout le bar est trop
petit pour toi non mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes
le banc n'est pas si petit que ça je
tiens c'est drôle de casse toi françois
je suis pas frileux ça me choquerait
même qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui la fait pas
d'efforts c'est pas le moment de faire
un effort à les couches ou alors je dois
douce je m'occupais de tout ça je crois
qu'il va savoir
mais oui je vais savoir mais oui je vais
savoir la ville d'essen pas françoise
était vachement sympa
r rien bien tu connais je vous en mets
rien vraiment vous êtes sympa et nous de
couverture ne casse pas une saveur par
contre si tu avais un oreiller là y'a
pas d'oreiller ya plus de rayer les
oreillers ça se fait plus alors t'es
gentil tu vas te coucher et tokyo allez
salut salut je vous remercie vraiment un
j'ai oublié quelque chose sur le palier
quoi mon putching ball
comment je l'avais laissée dans la
voiture avec le version je parle pas
pour ne le veulent pas parce que tu
qu'on lui même confirmé la semaine
dernière ont dû partir au maroc cet été
à ouarzazate
elle en rêvait abbas et le foot de
ouarzazate lui dit c'était uniquement
physique complètement physique
je connais la nana oui je retiens
répétera pas françoise du conflit des
retraites
josiane la tondeuse
oui
tu jures la copine de raul
merci vous êtes vraiment sympa
dégueulasse dégueulasse tu es vraiment
dégueulasse quoi si de neutre en fait tu
me le dire est en écoute tu l'as dit les
quatre heures du matin
alors ma pas s'engueuler à 4 heures du
matin j'ai mon concours de mam
il a peut-être fait une bêtise mais on
voit lui les tablettes en disputant six
shadow
[Musique]
c'est moi je vous emmerde encore vous
auriez pas du dentifrice certains
vaccins
tu peux après bill à la fête de pâques
c'est vrai je vous emmerde et je le paie
une gueule de bois alors sur la table en
temps tu fais de la villa c'était non
non je veux pas me déranger et merci à
maintenir une petite amy tu peux les
faire couler un battant qui viennent
voilà ce que tu peux être égoïste quand
les copains sont dans la merde phallus a
déplu leur toit les ségolistes j'adore
aussi égoïstement
moi j'ai unités merde quoi
non on pourrait peut-être allez-vous à
charlotte demain au nom j'ai montré que
j'avais téléphoné raul est ce qu'on lui
veut les voir charlotte il est vachement
psychologue
qu'est ce que c'est c'est moi vous
auriez pas de la gamme g à jouir cool
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu peux baisser
je te gêne je porte en plus un client
qui comprend j'ai eu ma gauche un peu
molle c'est mon point faible je ne
travaille pas tu commencé sur jument
récit et moi aussi je vais me ramasser
si je travaille pas ma souplesse de
pointer et moi c'est tout à l'heure je
suis moi comme ça ça va ça va
moi c'est ma pas aller au quotidien et
continue et occupe pas de loin et
pourquoi ça va pas est-ce que tu
commences il fait pas de bruit je peux
pas forcer sur mon gauche alors mais ça
fait mal ça n'a aucune importance je
vais travailler le jeu de jambes
silencieux juin vas-y vas-y qu'occupa
mois
[Musique]
super ouais je dis c'est vachement super
chouette c'est pas du schubert ctu
voisard remporté j'aurais l'idée du vent
a coupé tout cas c'est vachement
balancer comme morceau est dans le
rythme et m'arrête je t'emmerde avec mes
trucs ici je te revient mais je vais
plutôt regarder le vestiaire et mes
gants vas-y vas-y
mon
oh
je
[Musique]
c'est la brosse fille te jeter un mégot
parce que tu comprend sinon le cuir se
fendille ça craque elle quoi excuse moi
après je n'ai rien à [ __ ] que ça
craquait la charnière rien ne fut que ça
craquait l'entraîneur le championnat j'y
crois plus gérants de ma licence à la
fédération
oui aujourd'hui tu comment j'ai pu la
fois avant je croyais à mort je
m'entraîne et comme madagh uniquement
pour elle le maintenant j'ai tout
bousiller tu te dis l'amitié ne démonte
pas je vais me démonter tout était pour
l'une et où tesco qu'est ce qui m'a pris
de coucher avec cette nana
sanofi c'est elle qui m'a cherché à me
forcer à violer quand même presque ça
fait huit mois qu'ils me court après pu
faire de ton anniversaire
je m'étais aperçu de rien moi j'aurais
début moi non plus et après a commencé à
téléphoner la boutique la semaine
dernière à force d'être amère double je
suis accepté et a proposé ça par
téléphone mais n'ont pas de couches et
de me couper les cheveux
je croyais que c'est uniquement dans le
caniche général et associé ap deux
coiffeuses c'était son premier job on
s'en fout moi raul était pas là il
tourne à la télé ensemble
c'est après je suis en point que je
n'aime pas les cheveux secs
enfin ben arfa détail j'étais bouzid
invités qu'est ce que c'est qu'est-ce
que c'était encore qu'est ce que tu
faisais sur l'escabeau je faisais la
baïse la famille ma valise pour la
clinique faut qu'elle soit prête
ça va pas là dedans la valise la balise
meta des mois pour la faire la valise tu
te rends compte à 5km moi mais je sais
que tu prends mais c'est pas vrai oui
alors c'est pas toi qui la fera la
valise
alors faut bien que je me dis merde
toute seule remarque qu'on a l'habitude
ça fait des millénaires que des verts
tout seul phallocrate vous plantez vos
gardes et pousser c'est pas trop crevant
se balader dans le potager à ses patrons
en crevant c'est sa base il dit encore
que je fais rien c'est à cause de moi
mais à vous le voulez tu m'en veux pas
être enceinte et je vais dire une bonne
chose
d'accord je porte pas mais je supporte
mal au t1 salut tu profites tu as aimé
pour deux personnes je profite
moi je profite mais j'avais des
personnes mois non seulement c'est
devenu un hôpital psy mais en plus on
s'est agrandie gymnase aussi ya là je
dérange tiens c'est sûrement thales
on va pouvoir y ajoute de l'hospice
voila voila je m'excuse de la peau chez
boeing voyait sa forte impulsion
aujourd'hui si aujourd'hui et y aller ça
lâche mathieu est pour un a renoncé
printanier salou a tout mis bout à bout
y est pour beaucoup moins je suis chez
moi je dois partir pourquoi tu t'en vas
voir c'est à l'entraînement avant l
entrée nord ni à la traîne au teich
youtube sont prêts pour le match non
parce que si tu es jeune en train de
bois du charbon et il se sent frais on
t'expliquera si vous étiez vous avez
rien d'autre a expliqué m qu'on pourrait
groupe était considéré la possibilité
sera plus à l'aise souviennent du tacul
de l'école et surtout pas de nouveaux
soutiens apologie de vieux ça serait que
vous croyez tu pouvais passer de côté et
toi tu globe est tu peux pas savoir est
en ce moment est générale sur les genoux
c'est la télé depuis lundi ce sont des
jeunes à cheval et je n'ai pas monté
et y'a pas que les rangs j'ai
l'entrecuisse tout marché et là on va
tous appuyé nous demande un jaune hier
en ce moment question je suis
complètement et l'udc un josiane que je
suis venu pas d'accord d'accord
merde je l'oublié convaincu la descente
qui on apprend dans le quartier attends
tu prends de la vie neelie kroes de la
ville cette école secondes tu m'as et
gardien
alors j'adore
non mais je vais me préparer comme on
coule au noir était désagréable tu va le
préparer et on prend corps au pas leurs
quotas piste comme ça nous votre en
musique et après ça sonne mais bougez
pas refaire le retard ça coince ça lui
charles est de combien d'années étaient
visés n'ont ils pas la norme cei et
point là il n'est pas là il enfin s'il
est dans la pièce à côté il tapisse je
veux voir
bon ben tu bouges pas tu bouges pas je
vais pas venir
il vient charles a fait là il va dit
écoutez qu'on mette marit sait bien que
tu ne te reconnais pas est devenue folle
folle folle il entend par mois ça il
entend pas monsieur la france attend pop
rock la cible deux fois et vu aux avis
émis à moins que ça soit l'entraînement
à coup sûr le tampon s'appelera
expliquerait si d'individus deal est pas
sorti je fais exploser la porte et non
tu bouges pas de là je vais le prévenir
non mais pourquoi je te ferai je vous
dis ouais ou rouge vifs
ouais t'as entendu oui excuse moi
j'aurais pas dû venir
alors t'es gentil on va pas refaire
l'histoire tu es là on fait avec
il n'y a qu'une solution tu va la
trouver et vous allez vous expliquer où
vous voulez mais pas ici
ok alors tu y vas pas dit non mais t'as
rien compris ou quoi tu veux qu'on soit
tous avec son cocktail molotov parce
qu'elle n'a pas besoin oui
ah oui c'est au groupe non
révolutionnaire mais ça je m'en fous je
te donne sept minutes pour préparer ce
que tu vas lui dire c'est possible
chaque faire un cocktail bouteille de
whisky très drôle ouais c'est pas une
bouteille de whisky tient là mais tu
trouves vraiment la situation hilarant
bébé dans la voiture en soyez logique
oneriot l'explosif ouais je les dirai
forme et bien être touché par des
troubles depuis que c'est vrai ça f
j'ai l'impression de gêner si on cache
un bon alors je vais tout expliquer
alors j'ai voulu expliquer on va tous
santé parce que justement monsieur a
sauté une nana et madame ne se contente
pas d'être jalouse normalement jalouse
comme tout le monde
d'abord elle est suicidaire en plus est
là c'est pour ça c'était complètement
physique besoin de ce genre de truc
s'est jamais plaint tonique et
j'ai senti qu'ils gros cochon tu penses
vraiment 400 de la gueule la voilà je me
gêne encore le coach et voilà tout ça va
mais le temps faire le point alors ici
ecoute-moi jeremy ça fait deux jours que
tu es à transformer l'appartement en
salle de gym
maintenant c'est devenu un véritable
arsenal et tout ce que tu trouves à dire
celle je peux pas aller dîner et une
heure est atteint de jeu l'infraction
qui n est pas disposé à nous servir son
hôtel avec des glaçons qu'est ce qu'on
fait bon puisque déjà choisi la solution
de la lâcheté et qui me laisse toute la
responsabilité de la décision
je propose un truc on va négocier
raul tu vas lui dassier n'en mais
pourquoi leurs efforts allaient mal mais
c'est chez toi et tu y es tu y vas face
givet tiers face un jeu du pot moi j'ai
toujours dû pondre rien déjà dit on de
dépassement et il n'ya pas peux pas
encore me faire exclure et que je suis
sûr que tout va s'allonger sur twitter
mais qu'est ce que je vais lui dire
qu'est ce que je lui dis oui j'en sais
rien moi j'en sais rien distrait là les
terroristes pour les distraits toujours
métal est retourné toi vase il y en a
joué ya pas eu de triche mais mon
concours comment je vais passer mon
concours city va pas tu la joues et
s'inquiète des prothèses alors hall 1
sous les 2 3 ou s'ils écoutent et raul
excuse nous excusent nous ont pas fait
attendre
ouais on a un problème
j'ai un problème avec le papier peint on
la choisit to move délicat peu éclaire
accord parce qu'on croit pas mais
finalement c'est jamais évident les
raccords ouais surtout collation aux
bourses et toutes une escadrille
d'oiseaux qui panel oui parce qu'on tape
à des liens on a choisi des oiseaux des
grands oiseaux fous qu'est ce qui dit ça
va ça va il parle du papier peint des
oiseaux c'est bon c'est marrant parce
que quand j'étais gosse
j'avais aussi des grands oiseaux sur les
murs de ma chambre
la nuit il m'arrivait de me réveiller
alors j'allumais
[Musique]
ces rôles tu vas pas me croire si je te
crois que le croit mais quand j'étais
heureux je caressais le papier pas et
c'est drôle tu vois je me souviens du
toucher c'était comme une sensation de
lune et plus les plus visités des plumes
mais comme une sensation plus comme mais
c'est aussi comme une sensation de
n'être plumes et duvets et 2 c'était
comme une sensation de plumes et de
duvets au bout des doigts tu vois on est
on est con quand on est gosse savez
quand on est noir on est con et dit
quelque chose non et en toile ils
caressent le papier pompe un mélo alors
quand j'étais malheureux à l'époque
était mal oui ça m'arrive et oui fameux
soir aux idées là quand mon père m'avait
engueuler tiens je me souviens c'était
un dimanche
j'étais là je sais ça tu étais là émile
aussi était là
mes parents étaient sortis on était là
l'après midi ensemble il pleuvait pas de
signer en mer venait vous semblez un ben
oui on sent rien des emmerdes
alors pour déconner on avait décidé de
faire un plombage haute et kehl
je sais me paie lactée dentiste alors tu
aurais vu la gueule du club j'avais la
gueule moi tu crois que ça l'est prête
ça bah oui quoi c'est tu crois c'est
bien c'est toi qui toi c'est moi j'avais
la roulette alors au départ tranquille
en confiance parce que faut que je te
dise d'habitude s'est aussi arrogé spx
l'âge explique pas bien cityflitz pizza
où j'explique pas bien tu dirais tu
expliques tu l'as bien mais c'est pour
106 que texter pacte social s'est elle
non du teckel alors on la met les
saucisses mais cela semblait une
saucisse alors avec un moule à tête de
la saucisse
le corps de la saucisse et là que de ça
y est j'ai expliqué jacques becker non
c'est fou c'est tout c'est fou ce qu'on
a pu faire comme conneries tous les
trois et millet et millet nous là quand
on était gosses fashionita chaleco a
finalement émis c'est un comique
ah oui au second degré au second degré
et oui oui au second degré mais c'est un
comique quand même mais vous devez vous
fendre la gueule à l'ensemble des
gueules fendu de terry et surtout toi oh
merde ou rouge t'as talent au
fantastique et le parler au nom ici a
dit que j'étais un [ __ ] c'est bon
c'est bon là est ce déjà avant d'accord
d'accord là pour votre histoire là aussi
emile il a fait une connerie à mais je
connais toi je connais bien vous connais
et je peux t'affirmer ils t'adorent est
la meilleure je vais ce collège émile
veux je vais te dire et me avec les
filles et à toujours à quelle formidable
j'ai absolument tellement moi je
n'arrivais pas la cheville mais alors là
je me rends compte maintenant avec les
filles c'est moi qui t'ai un solo à huy
avery alors voilà je me souviens toi je
je draguais comme un fou mais jamais
rendu
et les lettres mal alors pour lui j'en
avais tellement les écrits avec un
garden pour te dire tandis qu'emile lui
c'est à dire mais pourquoi c'est tout ça
c'est pas bien tout est légal
dégueulasse tu m'as menti tout le temps
menti tu m'avais jurés qui avait jamais
rien eu avant moi c'est de la première
fois tu es intègre ne vient pas je fais
tout sauter taper sur jma avait duré
longtemps
j'irai que tous les deux par rapport aux
autres c'est exceptionnel c'est des
différents et moi pauvre comme je t'ai
cru à cette fois ça va pas je craque un
mois je fais touche mais que pour
arranger la lp et puis c'est moi qui me
fais engueuler n'était pas le but faut
continuer la négociation
info continuer la négociation d'un coach
joseph josiane s'activent à continuer la
médiation toujours eu la chance de faire
ça c'est charlotte ça c'est josiane 12
août dans la chambre j'ai une idée
géniale et je vais partir la change tout
puis partir par la fenêtre
c'est trop dangereux si si c'est
possible
sérielle m huit mètres c'est très
possible tu t'accroches al enseigne est
atteint comme ça facilement leur bord
supérieur du porche du basique je
suivais ça me donne le vertige c'est
rien du tout et c'est encore le vertige
ça s'apprivoise cette fois il a glissé
c'est possible je te dis c'est très
possible mais sa cuisine
il avait un côté c'est pas difficile tu
crois que j'ai que ça à [ __ ] ma mon
concours à merveille au centac de
tongres on court on se foutait tu vas
fady mélo c'est très bien monsieur roy
son balcon tu peux même pas gagné un
combat alors que l'on fait des vides
comment as tu sais qu'il faut pas lire
les périphériques
parce qu'il m'a dit
comment jamais vu à la maison jamais
venu enfin il m'a juste raccompagner
alors il est vu où il est parvenu
quand la semaine dernière fois tu
tournée en province
aux côtés de la peau des parce que parce
que quoi je vais t'expliquer je passais
par l'approché biotique par hasard le
razer non tu vas pas nous faire une
scène de jalousie mais cette jalousie je
marque de différent s'il te plait je
passais par les branches exotiques par
hasard que j'ai rencontré josiane qui
sortait alors j'ai proposé de la
raccompagner tu comprends je lui ai
juste de voir mon père me c'était un
entraînement tu qu'on voit mais je
comprendre et tous les deux vous vous
êtes entraînés pendant combien de temps
tout à fait de ma faute
tu piques toit basse et charlotte et là
c'est à cause de moi avec salaire était
complètement physique en attaque ne
manque pas de calais
franchois la cuc et la joie glisse pour
le tirer je suis tombé je viens d déjà
mais côté confidentiel du montant plus à
l'aise touche enfin les mecs dès que les
portes à vue c'est de la folie
mais je dis je le dis rj11 son t shirt
mais c'est ta mère ton t-shirt gamondi
dans la sphère j'appelle la police on
est bon pied je suis aux clauses et j'ai
froid était devenu fou vous les mois à
venir tout de suite mais qu'est ce qu'il
a fait il a glissé en faisant les
carreaux ouais c'est ça qui fait l'écart
on chez les copains il peut pas empêcher
ça fait mal et chez lui l'avenir les
arrivées nu mais on est entière c'est
vrai pour faire les toros c'est foutu
mais je les trouve à retourner la bouche
mais j'ai comme une odeur de gaz tout
l'est se sont tus travail d'approché
tu penses qu'à toi qu'as tu avianca des
champions quatre grandes bottes et moi
l'adorent et moi on ne se voit jamais tu
ne passes tandis que dans ta boutique
minarets ne plaît pas la boutique et
comme mardi matin je savais la landi
dans le désert j'en rêvais mais non tu
t'en fous du stade où je m'en fous
familiale et voilà ça fait peur qu'on
soit ensemble a sauté la première petite
[ __ ] venu c'était uniquement cgg veritas
allons maintenant sur quelque chose en
somme sans substance des passes à
charlotte où la presse que tu as fait tu
n'as même pas eu un geste citoyen qui
serait venu me trouver
on parlait m'expliquait mais non tu
paris iv comme un lâche pourquoi telle h
pourquoi tu as voulu fuir par la fenêtre
je faisais les tarots et alors
pas maintenant maman reste calme musique
africaine de mon sans tabou son concours
sans qu'aucun ne laissez pas votre fils
de jean todt fils mais c'est pas vrai le
complexe d'oedipe c'est vous qui l'avez
inventé veut dire sa moitié vous
apportez une table à langer
alors c'est eu trop d'efforts
[Musique]
rice ernotte je vais tomber mais
histoire est plus qu il m'a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
tous
[Musique]
et
7h10 mais qu'est-ce qui fait pour qu est
ce qu il fait bon ça on aurait dû aller
l'attendre tous en sont aux noms il est
tout seul qui est tellement nerveux jeu
qu'on compare je comprends pas parce
qu'il fait naître avec le champagne au
frigo l'attachante ayo il est il est
très bien comme ça ils arrêtent de fumer
il ya une femme enceinte ici excuse-moi
faudra s'habituer interdiction absolue
de fumer dans ta vie avec un boxeur pour
le sou on avait dit qu'on n'en parlait
plus un juge ou amazon j'avais mieux les
foyers qu'est-ce qui fait bon sang
qu'est-ce qui fait tabasser j'en sais
rien en fin de matinée
ag oui je vous dirais un petit
changement pourra venir à ce que tu nous
lâchant plus août on leur avait promis
je sais mais ces nouveaux j'ai un
programme par quoi la vache mois la tête
d'un mec
elle y raconte le ton programme non pas
maintenant choisi le nul kutina explique
toinon ses surprises non anon alors
saluons on veut le savoir maintenant
comprendra une surprise sanvensa ont
fait exploser la porte des balkans s'est
tenu loin
bon alors voilà
tiens est ce que c'est les billets ouais
on doit être demain à roissy à 10 heures
l'avion décollant 11h30 deux heures
après on sera à marrakech c'est là bas
j'ai réservé une voiture le soir on sera
à ouarzazate war z
mais alors la boutique chantier mots se
plaît pas aussi des syntagmes il écoute
c'est vachement mieux comme satisfaits
ils ont dans ton programme
tu veux prendre les gens viennent des
fois voilà c'est vrai je dirais 300 ça
passe et moderne tu déconnes passer du
mur aussi ça on a dit qu'on n'a pas
préparé alors le move est regrettée tué
ses deux mains pour tapisser moi j'ai
pensé à toi pour repeindre la fenêtre
les molettes l'extérieur c'était
l'émotion
cependant cette fois oui c'est moi avant
même pas ce que vous pouvez m'étonner
entendu pas là on l'attend assez normal
la délibération du jury très longue
comme serez vous tue pas c'est bon on y
fait incroyable entre nous a fait tous
promettent de ne pas y aller
rassurez vous personne le ma vie mais
j'ai est nouvelle j'ai rencontré le
concert du conservatoire
il a été extraordinaire et variés pas le
concierge est un connaisseur et la copie
d'un concours
il est tellement chaud qu'il a fallu
réaccorder deux fois le piano mozart
mozart à mozart fantastique je fais de
jury je les ai que gérer ça tu dis moi
satie la première gymnopédies
fantastique
cgg attaque est grave très grave
après après j'ai merdé
deuxième accessit deuxième ouais c'est
pas grave
et vous les mecs ça va on voulait pas
demander à oui oui mais je te dis c'est
pas grave hein donc à love qui a joué
comme un dieu la vache milka losc et
mais qui se serrent amical offs qui
tient au ski c'est le premier prix quoi
michael et utd ses vols et ont pris part
à l'étranger tu laisses moi là je suis
crevée
vous partez déjà
oui
excusez nous on l'a on a prouvé à des
copains d'aller les voir au théâtre à
l'odéon il joue claudel c'est dur 6h
faut conduire comme ça salut salut mon
tapis vous vous tirez aussi oui excusez
nous on part à ouarzazate
là maintenant non non demain matin on
n'a encore rien préparé mais l'annoncé
je voulais te dire tout à l'heure aux
hôtes en fait proche l'a tant fait pas
puis je voulais vous dire à moore un
défoncé vous à mort je crois que vous
avez du temps à rattraper avec 50 watts
merci
en fait une gueule même regardez pas
comme si j'avais la peste mais tu as
raté son concours
ben oui j'ai raté oui j'ai raté pour la
passe flinguer et c'est tout l'effet que
ça te fait
je vais prendre une douche noir d'une
torche
non mais tu complètement guérie semences
à mon chéri mais tu as raté ton concours
tu entends tu as raté ton concours tout
le mal qu'on s'est donné pour en arriver
là non mais tu te rends compte
tu sais qu'on a tout sacrifié pour toi
ton pouvoir père et moi tout c'est que
j'ai tout fait mais tout fait pour t d
pour préserver tu es donc tu le sais
jour après jour je me suis privé oui
privé pour organiser sa vie et toi tu as
tous les organiser tout il a fallu que
tu te maries que tu vis dans le désordre
entourée de fous et que par dessus le
marché tu fasses à l'enfant à sa femme
sort maman sort
antoine tu as raté de concours sort
maman
ça
rabat et de coucou
d'habitude on le coup plutôt le cordon
loin vache c'est douloureux
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir on va
continuer patates et continuer
dommage que le concert je n'ai pas été
dans le jury quoi rien et ta carrière
les bébés l'avenir qu'est ce qu'on va
faire maintenant mais t'en fais pas j'ai
vu le type de la boîte de nuit
il m'a vu jouer maintenant s'est il
engagé on pourra bouger vous faites
c'est ça bout c'est oui je crois que ça
suffit pas de ma mère l'a 1
vas-y de nuit raison tu m'a même pas
défendu bon je sais parler à deuxième
accessit faut quand même pas exagérer
nous c'est quoi un deuxième accessit
j'suis des maximes la peau j'avais
d'autres choses moi tu comprends les
tournées les disques le concert pour que
je les ramasse alors elle est quand même
dur la transition pianiste à pigalle
faut que je me fasse
jean louis martin barbaz j'arrive là
j'assume le coup et c'est vous qui me
fait la gueule mais bon il prenez vous
pour une bête à concours
c'est ça un juke box pour tubes
classiques
allez vas-y mais sans balle dans la
belle et la bête à concours assez un
marché vas-y s'est passé pour toi tu
boxes avec je vous suis pas parce que
pour cent balles siffler mais toutes ses
tripes
allez vas-y parce que moi aussi je sévis
toutes mes tripes légèreté et aléria la
[ __ ] j'ai un deuxième accessit rominou
t'as rien compris
si j'ai tout compris tu crois les vivre
avec le premier de la classe et tout
aperçoit que tu couches avec un deuxième
accessit alors sept places chacun désolé
il faudra s'habituer
[Musique]
avant
mon
tu pleures c'est beau ça dit c'est
toujours beau tu n'as jamais aussi bien
joué
merci de dire au jury
mais nous tout le monde partout
j'ai mal réagi tu sais je m'en fout de
ton concours c'est de l'orgueil
uniquement de l'orgueil mais pas de
l'orgueil que moi embrassement fais
gaffe du jeune fille fera c'est nous
deux qui compte
rien qu'à nous deux toujours nous donner
la carrière qu'est ce que tu fais de la
tarière red bull ou c'est important la
carrière non minouche tedder normal ne
peut pas supporter les deuxième accessit
tu voi t il je suis sûr c'est un garçon
c'est
j'ai trouvé un prénom aujourd'hui ouais
on l'appellera eric eric satie
comme on revient on va sortir on va les
eaux kinopanorama ordonne aux usa story
médecine on l'a déjà vu à sa cour moi ça
fait rien ça nous a porté bonheur c'est
mon la féerique et puis après on va se
faire une pizza
mais alors une pizza comme ça parce que
tu sais maintenant
l'hépatite j'en ai plus rien à [ __ ]
mais alors rien
allez moi on va louper la séance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la pièce la pièce que nous venons
d'avoir le plaisir de jouer devant vous
et de michelle lang l'ine
[Applaudissements]
le décor et jean philippe bertrand les
costumes de donald cardwell
[Applaudissements]
la chorégraphie et de jacky perron
avec marie sagesse
[Applaudissements]
henri courseaux
sonia sariel
[Applaudissements]
la mise en scène de maurice risch
avec deux miss provence
jean bardet
[Applaudissements]
et sabine azéma
[Musique]